[Music]
- I'll go I issued a challenge to our
viewers to our fans to try to find a
mistake on our show see if you can catch
us making a mistake
anyway I dared my fans to try to make
chunk meat out of the master all right
well ladies and gentlemen the responses
have been pouring in really so far for
viewers have stepped up to the plate on
the show oh there's a lot more than that
writing in it when I said pouring in I
mean they really haven't pointed we've
selected for no literally thousands of
grinding guys so we selected for 4
viewers stepped up to the plate for have
gone down swinging well now a fan named
Daniel Robinson thinks he found a
mistake in our show he posted a video on
YouTube where he comments on a sketch we
did with pee-wee Herman I recently found
an error in your program
I was watching his show and you did a
skit with pee-wee Herman about Ash
Wednesday it was okay
had Jesus and Easter chick the devil
pirates and then one final character
Frankenstein and of course Frankenstein
my only issue with this is it's not
Frankenstein what is clear is that the
monster does not have a name the
scientist that creates the monster is
named Frankenstein I'm hoping you can
correct it for next time
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm sorry did he ever get to the point a
little less wine over here brevity let's
get some coffee into the mic pronto
well first of all sorry Daniel I think
you spent way too much time in that
creepy room of yours you're maintaining
that it's Frankenstein's monster and
he's not called Frankenstein guess what
people are always making that claim and
they're all wrong and you're wrong to
guess what I looked into it turns out
that you've made a huge mistake
the monsters name is Frankenstein I was
right check out this rare piece of
historical footage
you're not helping this rare piece of
historical footage of Frankenstein
arriving in this country at Ellis Island
your name's Frankenstein's monster
alright well now it's just Frankenstein
next
[Applause]
footage was very hard to dig up anyway
who knows why they had it hey and
speaking of mistakes Daniel let's talk
about your decorating faux pas wine
bottle lamps dude is that really the way
you want to go Andy tell me why it's
dangerous well according to my mother
wine vapors can build up on those things
if the heat from the lamp lights it up
it could turn into a bomb and cut that
pretty Judge Nelson face of yours I got
a thing about judge oh oh alright anyway
that's not the point the challenge still
stands ok I'll put you in the la bamba
Club if you're not careful I don't even
know what that means if you think this
show on air if you think you've spotted
if you think you spotted an error on our
show report it at chin koco.com slash ha
ha I found an error we will sort it out
right here on the air let's see if
you've got what it takes to make Chuck
meat out of the maestro that's right
[Applause]